Do females really select the best penis to
mate with?
… Come on.
Hi Guys, Crystal here for DNews.
Ready to talk about penises?
Well Harvard scientists working with international
collaborators have discovered that the penis
of a Caribbean lizard may be evolving faster
than their other physiological traits.
This is a result of sexual selection that
contributes to genetic as well as genital
diversity in the species and leads to questions
as to why this occurs:
Do females, who have the power of mate choice,
select the “best” penis for them?
Or, is this diversity the result of a sexual
arms race with male lizards looking to reduce
female control of reproduction?
Well, lets get into the dirty details.
Lizard penises are different from human ones.
For one thing, male lizards (and others in
the order Squamata) don’t just have one
penis, they have a pair of organs called hemipenes.
Don’t get too excited, they usually only
use one at a time, and hemipenes means “half
penis” so … Anyway, these organs are kept
inside the body for day to day activities,
and then one becomes externalized by erectile
tissue for reproductive purposes.
The scientists who performed the study used
comparative methods to ask whether there was
more variability in hemipenis shape (length
and width), than of non-genital traits like
limbs and dewlaps - a flap of skin under a
lizzard’s throat.
This is an important question to answer because
increased diversity would imply an increased
evolutionary rate for genitalia.
To ask this question, scientists examined
hemipenes and body morphology from 5 samples
of 25 species of Anolis lizard in an attempt
to represent the “diversity of microhabitat
specialists in the Caribbean anoles”.
What they found, when they compared measurements
is that many very closely related lizards
have hemipenes very different from each other!
Scientists were able to calculate the rate
of change necessary to produce such different
genital features and put this information
in the context of a relative lack of diversity
in limbs and dewlaps to conclude that the
genitalia of caribbean Anoles lizards evolve
approximately six times faster than other
morphological traits.
Genitalia is frequently used to differentiate
similar species, but no one has done a quantitative
measure of increased evolutionary rate until
now.
And the speed of evolution is so different
that it begs the question, why?
Well, the scientists who performed this study
assumed that the rapid evolution of male genitalia
was a result of co-evolution with the female
and proposed two hypotheses: either the evolution
occurred through “cryptic female choice”
where females drive selection through personal
preference, or “sexually antagonistic coevolution”
an attempt on the part of male lizards to
reduce the female influence on reproduction.
More studies are needed to determine which
of these is happening here, but what do you
think?
Subscribe to DNews and let us know your thoughts
in the comments down below!
And for science and more follow me on Twitter
@PolycrystalhD
What do you think?
Inexplicable female choice or sexual arms
race?
Let us know in the comments down below.
And you can come find me on Twitter @PolycrystalhD